claude goasguen pour le groupe l'est
républicain merci monsieur le président
cela va question s'adresse en continuité
d'ailleurs avec le ministre des affaires
étrangères à propos de la visite récente
qui nous a surpris je dois dire mais les
méandres de la diplomatie française
surprendront toujours la visite de
monsieur le président rohani en france
boudée de donner une partie de la
réponse qui est une réponse économique
intéressés et commerciales que nous
entendons très bien mais cette
habitation peut pas allen la visite peut
paraître surprenante si on se souvient
quand même des réticences fortes que
vous aviez exprimé lors de la signature
et des longues négociations et nous
avons signé
fallait-il signé ce traité est
actuellement vous l'avais dit en
application suspendu à des réserves
alors il ya ce paradoxe quand même qui
intervient et que vous avez rappelé tout
à l'heure le gouvernement américain qui
s'était empressé de signer campent
désormais sur une attitude très dure
d'interprétation des réserves
et vous qui étiez quand même le
défenseur d'une attitude très dure à la
signature vous donnez le sentiment en
tout cas et vous le confirmer en partie
par rencontre du président de la
république et du président roh a dit que
vous avez une attitude plus souple on a
on a un minimum d'interprétation après
ce que vous avez dit mais quelle est
votre position définitive on aimerait le
savoir mais peut-être serait-il opportun
de rappeler un certain nombre de choses
aux présidents rois ni dans la
discussion il aura avec le président
hollande et que je rappelle la question
des droits de l'homme en iran sur
oignies le modéré le modéré bien connu
c'est vrai que son prédécesseur était un
fou furieux
aecon est toujours le modèle est
quelqu'un dans ces conditions mais il ya
eu néanmoins 700 exécutions capitales
700 exécutions capitales depuis le début
de l'année le gouvernement iranien vous
pouvez lui poser la question aussi
entente il continuer à soutenir le
hezbollah qui soutient le qui met en
difficulté le gouvernement libanais je
terminais israël vous pouvez lui poser
la question je croyais que vous étiez le
le plus fervent défenseur de la lutte
contre assad et vous avez là son allié
et puis est-ce que je peux signer
quelque chose merci monsieur wang n la
parole à monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères développement
international cher monsieur goasguen
j'ai répondu sur la partie commerciale
mais en ce qui concerne la visite du
président et rouani je vous rappelle que
le président de la république française
avait rencontré déjà deux fois le
président roy dit aux nations unies et
peut-être pas vous mais vos collègues en
général nous demande avec juste raison
d'avoir une politique indépendante qui
ne s'aligne sur personne et qui est des
conversations avec les uns et avec les
autres c'est ce que nous faisons
sans jamais compromettre sur les
principes lorsque le président rani va
venir la semaine prochaine
le président de la république a même
juré l'occasion aussi de rencontrer nos
lui parleront de tous c'est à dire que
bien évidemment il y aura un aspect
commercial mais il y aura surtout un
aspect politique c'est à dire nous
parlerons du liban nous parlerons
d'israël nous parlerons de la syrie et
samedi prochain je ne rendrai à vienne
pour discuter de la syrie
mon collègue arrive sera là et je le
dirai la même chose que je lui ai dit
déjà ya quelques jours en syrie
nous avons des divergences profondes en
ce qui concerne la syrie nous
considérons que il n'est pas possible
que à terme ce soit monsieur bachar al
assad qui gouverne la syrie et nous
considérons points supplémentaires
monsieur à sable qu' il n'est pas
envisageable
tuez moi excusez moi et tu es moi deux
fois mais tu es moi deux fois et que je
les vois deux fois nous considérons que
il n'est pas possible que les iraniens
qui en fait on des troupes en syrie même
si elle appelle ça des causses et
militaires restent en en syrie
durablement et là dessus nous avons une
divergence fondamentale avec les
iraniens
nous tiendrons ce langage nous sommes
monsieur goasguen indépendant nous
parlons avec les uns et les autres mais
nous ne mettons pas notre drapeau dans
notre poche
merci monsieur ministre la parole est à
monsieur thierry roland